at least he made it
that's what the mother of 11 year old
Yousef Abu dawood tells us he's in an
intensive care unit after being wounded
in his abdomen by shrapnel and by a
bullet in his legs
Youssef says he went to a market in the
old city of nablis to buy a sandwich
but he ran into Israeli forces
didn't know the Israeli Army was
reigning he went to buy some food he
might have stayed to look on but he's a
kid what kind of danger a boy his age
can pose 11 Palestinians were killed
during the raid on Wednesday thousands
came to this Community Hall to mourn and
pay their respects among those killed
was a child and three elderly men dozens
of other people were wounded and
hospitals overwhelmed
Elias is a nurse as the wounded are
being brought in he was called to the
emergency room he tried to resuscitate a
wounded man it wasn't until that patient
was declared dead that he realized it
was his father
I pulled the curtain and saw him I
didn't want to believe my eyes I took a
closer look I turned his head I realized
it was my father I just didn't want to
believe it
the Israeli forces say the raid was
aimed at members of armed groups but
with a high number of fatalities many
here say Israel is trying to deter
people from resisting Israel's
occupation choices that they offer the
Palestinians is one either one of the
two things either to go and to resist
and to say no and to just to hold your
ground and the the price would be
exceptionally high or you go out and
declare that you are surrendering that
you are a defeated people a general
strike was announced across the occupied
West Bank in protest against the raid
Palestinians say they have few other
options and surrendering isn't one of
them
the occupied West Bank